[Music]
andrea is with us in denver hi andrea
how are you
hi good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thanks for taking my question i'm a
little nervous so bear with me no
troubles um
so my husband and i started baby step
two and since mid-october we paid off um
15 grand on one debt which is my car
very good but the baby steps have caused
us to look at our mortgage and we
realized that we're just over that 25
percent mark but on a 30-year
and even before this he and i have been
going back and forth and we just cannot
seem to make a decision on
whether we actually want to stay in this
house because we're a little bit scared
of the real estate market but some of
the things that we go back and forth on
is
we own a little bit of land
um which he believes it might be a good
investment um for development down the
road um but one of the other things is
we're also 30 minutes away from
everything in town um
and to make the house what we really
want we would have to put about 160 000
into it
um and so we're just kind of stuck on on
what to do and i i wanted to get your
advice
what's your household income
it's 110 right now
okay the way you said right now makes me
think it's going to change
yes he's looking into he's in law
enforcement he's looking to promote
which would add about twenty thousand
dollars um to the income and that would
be which would make you
which make you easily within your 25
then
um i'm not 100 sure what a 25 would be
on a 15 year close enough though i mean
you're not going to be far off so okay
so then the question comes where do you
want to live and when
yeah i i hear this is less of a
confusion you want to move and he
doesn't that's what it sounds like
that's a little bit of what's what's
there yes that sounds like it's all of
it
um yeah i go back and forth a lot um
some days i really want to move and be
closer to town because i'm driving my
kids back and forth between school and
activities i feel like i'm in the car
you know a couple hours every day so the
piece of land is uh you own it free and
clear
no we owe uh 360 on it
how much acreage is it
um it's 13 acres it's right outside of a
little town that's really developing um
really kicked up development
um like i said i really go back and
forth no no no i didn't ask about it
it's an easy question you don't go back
and forth because is it closer to town
or further from town
it's 30 minutes away from our church
school and our family what are you now i
feel like i'm
i'm 30 minutes away from that we have a
tiny little town that doesn't so you're
an hour out now and this makes you 30
minutes out
no you're 30 30 minutes out and this
makes your three minutes out
three we are 30 minutes away from
everything like our school in our church
today but there's a small town today yes
okay what would you be if you were on
the land
it is the 30 minutes
the town
they're both 30 minutes away from
everything
no the town that's developing it's about
five minutes from here but right now we
don't have the school and the church and
everything else so they're just now
kicking up development which is why my
husband would like to stay on it until
development comes our way and we're here
for you on the property now
we are on the property now yes oh that's
why i was confused i thought it was two
pieces of property you live on the 13
acres
yes oh crap okay here's where i'm
confused
move to town
yeah charlotte
why won't you just say what you want to
do something is keeping you from saying
what you really want to do well her
husband thinks she's a big time real
estate developer and she don't want to
spoil his dream that is true
yes
there is a big and she's sick of driving
kids through traffic because he wants to
develop something that's probably about
five years too early way too early
and if he had 360 000 in cash to buy it
i'd say buy it but he doesn't so no
you're selling you're in debt sitting or
you're playing real estate speculator
instead of building a home
or everything slows down in this little
tiny town out there just goes
kaput for the next 15 years and sits
and y'all are on a worthless piece of
land yeah sell it yeah shall it move
enjoy your life
you know
like it it sounds easier what's the heck
anything can do with the 25 issue though
yes it's got to do with you don't want
to live there and you're trying to come
up with math reasons to tell your
husband why you want to move
is that fair
um i think that the 25 thing just made
us go
re-look everything there you go um okay
well it's tight
and
it's far away
okay
and and that's on one side of the scale
on the other side of the scale is we
might make a bunch of money if we split
this up into lots someday
yeah but you're not real estate
developers you're building a family
right now and you're in law enforcement
don't be a real estate developer move
okay
it's just there's a lot listen real
estate development's a pain in the butt
i do a bunch of it it's a pain in the
butt
you're dealing with city people and
codes people and planning people and
oh my god it'll make you want to shoot
yourself it's that all of a sudden
there's a rock underneath the drill
you're digging
that when you hear that sound it's 1500
bucks an hour
okay so uh yeah i'm in tennessee where
there's a lot of rock but yeah
yeah this is you're trying to combine
too many different things here um you
caught that john good catch and trying
to use one set of metrics to just say
what's in your heart and which in your
heart is you want to move yeah yeah if
you bought the exact same
math
closer to town i'd be okay with it yeah
that's his income the life you want yeah
his income's going up and you got your
life back you're not driving 30 minutes
to everything
yeah you're um you moved out to the
country
and uh time to move back to town
that's it it's not as much fun as it
sounds i moved out to the country into
this nice subdivision but it's way out
in the middle of nowhere and i feel like
country people might you know when i was
a kid country my family and stuff they'd
be like we have to get a list because
we're going to get you know getting a
trip up to town oh hey you got to get
ready to go to town live out the woods
and that's you have to get ready to go
you have to get ready to go do something
we're going to like going to the markets
an event yeah and the fact that i just
said to the market makes me feel like
that's like i've been there too long
yeah you opened your mouth your old man
just came out exactly you don't go to
the grocery store when you live out
there
you'll load the kids up yeah i'm telling
you yeah it's fine there's nothing wrong
with it
i did not anticipate that part of this
last move yeah because that that home we
had was was too much and it was a great
opportunity to sell it but it was right
in the middle everything yeah i mean i
could just you know like fall off the
hill of the house and i was right in the
middle of everything
not now i'm playing my gas station trip
only thing i'm close to now is this
office
i just come to work a lot